i think people will answer the question  who am i differently depending on the  context in which they are if they're  traveling outside of the country and  someone asks who are you they might very  well say their nationality i am canadian  i am chinese etc the fact that they  actually do that when they're outside of  their country shows how fundamental it  is because they're not saying i am a  tennis player  i am someone from you know this small  village for example in france and so  that shows you the centrality of  nationality especially when we get  outside of our own borders  will people answer the question who am i  and respond with their nationality or  citizenship in their everyday life not  necessarily but on an important day like  election day they might do so